le réseau dense a contraint les uns
n'avait pas peur des autres on était
chacun dans son coin tout ces problèmes
étaient les nôtres ou chantier
même refrain le petite histoire des
quotidiens
en ce qu elle est là vincent virtuel
disait qu'on sait mais sans logiciel
souviens toi
suite
relations
[Musique]
je vais
sion
la pluie
on a
dhainaut parfois on avait des rêves
grands chacun
ce même désir d'être les premiers
mais reculer les anciens on rêvait
trèbes été soulevée corps des armes puis
la nuit des temps arme puis la gare aux
idées nouvelles
[Musique]
le même heure de temps pas de trême
souviens toi
sauveur soir
souviens toi ma génération
[Musique]
ma fidèle ma génération
le maire
ma génération
[Musique]
hubert
j'ai toujours
et toi
[Musique]
imaginaire
tu seras toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pascal obispo est prêt ou gratos
bienvenue à la havane génération là
c'est ma génération
ces deux générations que je suis content
merci